[موسيقى]
هلا هاي المشروبات كعادي ممكن تقول فينك
تقول لك عادي يعني
انا ابني عم بشوفني عم بشتري صوص بجي هو
بيكبر بيرجعوا
متوارث
20 سنه انا كان في ولاد صغار يجوا ابوهن
على الموتور الثامن
[موسيقى]
انا محمد العسلي ابو حمدو من سوريا حلب
مدينه الباب عمري 42 سنه
والله بالنسبه لمهنه السوس صار لي حوالي
بشتغل فيها من عام تقريبا 2006 صلي عشرين
سنه تقريبا هيك يعني
والمهني والله انا اخذتها من الوالد الله
يرحمه
الله يرحمه ما كان يعني يشتغل فيها كان بس
هيك يعني يشتغلها في البيت
يوزع للجيران للاهل للاقارب فانا هيك خطره
تعبانه الفكره اني يعني ازولك مهنه
وبلشت فيها سبحان الله وربك هو اللي وفقني
فيه والحمد لله رب العالمين
[موسيقى]
هلا انا بشتغل ثلاث شغلات عرق سوس المعروف
عنا هون اسمه السوس والتمر الهندي
والجلاب جديد طبعا على الساحه صاير هلا
بعد ما اجت المناطق من كافه مناطق سوريا
ماده عشبيه بحته يعني فنحن بنبلش في شغله
اول شيء بفضل الكيس عامل بنحط تحت ايدنا
طشط من فضل كيس كيلو وين بدنا اياه يعني
وبنحط له ماده الخميره اللي هي الكربون
ومن بعدها بنفرد فيهم بنعطي شويه فرق فرق
لمده تقريبا ساعه بنعيفه ثلاث اربع ساعات
خمس ساعات بنبلش بقى مرحله التصفيه
التمر اللي عندي عباره عن عصير اول شيء
بنجيب ظروف ظروف هيك مكبوسه انصاص كيلوات
او كيلوات
بنجيب اول شيء بنشقها في التمر
بعمل المي من اي فاي لفتره هيك بالمي لما
يطلب
على المصفي بعد المصفايه كمان من الصفيه
كيس يعني مشان يطلع صافي ونقي والسكر
بنحطه على الطلب يعني
[موسيقى]
والله بالنسبه لهاي المشروبات يعني
الصراحه
قديمه جدا بس ما يمرته بتاريخ ولا يعني
الصراحه ما خطر اليوم اني افكر ايش قد صار
لبس مصلحه عريقه جدا يعني هلا بالنسبه الي
بقول
والله انا نصيحه مني كافي يعني انت جرب يا
اخي ما لك خسران شي وهو يطير فيه فائده
الصراحه يعني
[موسيقى]
اول ما كان الاول والاخير هو شريكي ورفيقي
ابو احمد
هذا اول واحد كان معي وكان مشجع الي كتير
الصراحه ابو احمد هلا بدايه الامر انا
والله الصراحه اشتغلته في البيت يعني كانت
عائلتي ساعدتني امي ساعدني الله يرحمها
بعدين صارت تطورنا شوي صرنا هون بالمحل
فكان شاركت ابو احمد
وبلشنا انا وياه لما الكبر شغلنا وكثرت
يعني صار الطلب كثير وزايد صار اجباري
حطينا عمال وعندي هلا الحمد لله 10 عمال
انا بشتغلوا عندي
انا ما اخذت من اساس كمهنه ربحيه لا والله
انا اخذتها هيك انا بعشقك وبحبها وبحب
الناس المجتمعين قدامي يعني لما الشخص
اللي عندك اكيد هو يحبك وناسيك لمت عليك
فهي هي العشق في المصلحه ولا ما هي مصلحه
ربحيه لا والله
[موسيقى]
لبس العربي لا اتفضل تسالني عليه مرتبط
حصرا بهالمصلحه هاي لانه هي المصلحه اساسا
قديمه واللبس العربي في الكلور وقديم
والناس بتحبك وانت لابسه هيك فهوي يعني
يعني اللبس مرتبط اصلا بمصلحتنا
نداء دمعه ابو حمدو واللي ما بنسوها واللي
متابعين معنا
يعني هيك كل عام وانتم بخير وان شاء الله
كل سنه وانتم سالمين ونضل نشوفكم بخير هاي
اهم شيء
[موسيقى]